enfin pour faire un sketch comique il
faut d'abord des interprètes comique
regardez cet homme il n'est pas comique
il ne fera jamais rires donc à 10 même
qu'ils feraient mieux d'arrêter le
métier ça va je mon travail correctement
j'ai une famille à nourrir tous en
revanche voici maintenant la véritable
individus comique une nature drôle
irrésistiblement comment vas-tu de poids
là ça va
maintenant que nous avons les comédiens
il nous faut les idées on nous dit
souvent en le voyant dans la rue mais
comment faites vous pour trouver autant
d'idées où allez vous chercher tout ça
etc
mais dans la vie de tous les jours tout
simplement écouter cette conversation
bonjour albert bonjour robert tu vas
bien maintenant je me suis déchiré ma
veste
alors c'est pas de veine et puis je me
suis fait deux trous aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
moi j'espère que ma mère va pouvoir mais
recoudre là moi aussi les dents ouais
acheter un nouveau costume pour
remplacer oui à deux couleurs aux basses
et bien allez salut salut el bez vous
avez vu plutôt plein sinistre même
regarder ce que nous force à nourrir nos
galériens de la bonne humeur vont
réussir à en faire allez-y les gars
bonjour lise ses épaules
vous avez vu un gaz hilarant dans les
cinq premières secondes
c'est ça l'efficacité maintenant
regardons toutes les ressources que peut
nous apporter le calembour
bonjour albert sava albert bonjour lis
ça va l'isq collet police cepol aux bas
rhinois apple tu vas bien non je ne suis
déchiré ma veste
or vu à l'heure tu t'es fait un accroc
paul
j'ai vu la différence
trois gags trois gags dans les 30
premières secondes du sketch c'est ça
l'efficacité bouvard bravo les gars nous
sommes là aussi pour toujours dans la
bonne humeur et la joyeuseté instruire
le public
les ducs et lui élever son niveau
culturel
c'est normal regardez ce que par
conséquent nous sommes capables de faire
toujours dans ce but allait il dit moi
apple tu t'es acheté un nouveau resto
oui à deux couleurs un bon lesquels
rouge et noir rouge et noir mais c'est
un style
voilà le type même de l'ex hollande
blague culturel cette fameuse
interjections et la caricature bien
connue d'une des expressions favorites
d'un homme politique
mais c'est aussi vous voulez vous en
êtes rendu compte une allusion au
merveilleux livre de stendhal le rouge
et le noir et ça vous le saviez
évidemment les références culturelles ne
sont pas toujours compréhensible par
tous aussi les grands professionnels du
comique comme c'est le cas chez philippe
bouvard
on recourt souvent à des accessoires de
vrais professionnels
alif illégaux didon paul tu t'es acheté
un nouveau casting il ya de quoi
or mon week-end rouge et noir rouge et
noir mais c'est un scandale
vous avez vu la différence vous avez été
tout de suite beaucoup plus nombreux à
rire mais oui bien sûr nous pouvons les
applaudir
cette grande leçon d'efficacité un seul
conseil à vous donner à vos crayons fait
temps au temps et à bientôt